[Music]
I'm Joey and I'm here in the industry
solutions neighborhood of our expo floor
looking at this great energy all these
people are really excited and I'm
standing with the lock who's gonna show
us the n-c-double-a demo gonna take it
away yeah so this is our second year at
Google cloud being the official cloud
provider of the n-c-double-a our theme
is know what your data knows so we've
been working with the actual NCAA Data
basketball data to make a lot of
insights and predictions so let's still
get one we just had a national title
game Virginia and Texas Tech and what
we're looking at here is the number of
possessions each team will have in
regulation so we predicted that the
number will be 63 or fewer and it was 59
in regulation so it was right well we've
done a bunch more so one of the other
things we did was we looked at a data
studio dashboard so data studio another
tool made by Google allows you to
visualize your data yeah we have
developed a bunch of different metrics
for all these teams in n-c-double-a you
can see them on the bottom here score
control clutch nest discipline etc but
we wanted to surface that data in a way
that people could use filter and sort so
this has all the 353 teams but if we
just want to look at the champion we can
go here and select champion only boom
Virginia and now we can see where they
rank in all the different categories
yeah it's a good sport for clutchless
yeah so the ranks are right there so you
can tell it's seventh out of 353 teams
pretty good the third and sport control
they they're a deserving champion so you
said this is data studio which we know
is for visualization which is really
cool
but you need some other cloud tools I
think bigquery played a big part in this
yeah show me how that works yeah so the
first thing we have to do is write make
a pipeline to ingest the data so this is
a small screen here but I'll show you
this is on our Google cloud blog we
describe the entire pipeline of how we
built this data and you can see there's
a bunch of stuff and then we get to
bigquery right in the middle and I'm a
data scientist I want stuff in bigquery
because then I can go and do all my
stuff right so bigquery let's do it and
then what we do from there is we take
the data we do a lot of manipulations
and to build that metric like Spore
control we have to write a bunch of code
alright so got the cloud blog and then
you
also posted on medium right yeah more
fun insight yeah so on medium what we
did was we wanted to talk more in depth
about how we built this metric so one we
wanted to describe in detail for the
techno people but also talking about the
basketball contacts so you have this
thing how the final score can lie score
control right and in here we go through
a couple example games where teams
control the score differently but then
again we get back to bigquery so here is
a long query and again it looks fairly
complicated and it kind of is but it
actually is when you think about how you
go about doing this calculation bigquery
makes it pretty easy with these
aggregation functions and it runs really
fast and it may be long but it's easy to
read and and it runs really fast gets us
our results for all thousands of games
in a matter of seconds and then we can
move forward and do other stuff
I love scale power now you'd one more
thing in this blog right at the bottom i
thought i was playing with your what was
that an interactive scatter watch we
keep going here eventually we get to a
point where we see this scatter plot
which spots all 353 teams in their
school colors and shows their difference
between the score control and a
different measure I like it so if anyone
wants to kind of find out at home they
can search n-c-double-a on our cloud
blog or they can look across the cloud
GCO slash march madness oh nice I know
it's a little bit past March but the
tournament is still fresher than I am so
it should it should be should be fine
well thank you so much for talking to me
okay so now we're still in the
n-c-double-a zone we were talking to
Abby who's one of our students who got
to do a really cool integration for this
whole project that I think is really
like fun to talk about right yeah all
right second away tell me about the
overview of what you built sure so
basically the way our campaign ended up
starting was we split into two teams
first was competitiveness which looks at
how close our games how many lead
changes are there basically how exciting
is a game towards the end of the time
and the second team was explosiveness
and this is all about runs so for
example maybe in the last five minutes
of the game a team went on a 15 to 5 run
what that means is that the team scored
15 points and the opponent only scored 5
points ok nice ending yeah so the more
explosive a team is the more likely they
are to go on these really big runs and
the less time they take to go on these
runs again that increases their
explosiveness
so that was the team that I was on and I
got to do some really cool data analysis
and exploration of the data set that we
were given basically the way that it
started was through bigquery now one
thing you should know is that I had
never actually used bigquery before in
my life uh-hum they don't just teach big
weird all the students these days I
guess not all right now so you got
started was it intimidating at all a
little bit it was nice because it runs
using sequel which is a language that I
had learned in the past and some
language that almost every developer
knows so when I actually got into the
big query portal I realized wow this is
really easy there's an interface where I
can paste in my query I just need to put
in the data set that I'm varying from
musics in my ear and you get the preview
you can get you can get a preview right
in bigquery actually yeah that's good
for testing and another great thing was
that I could copy this query
word-for-word
and use it in Google collab which is
where I was at doing my actual analysis
in Python okay and using Google clouds
bigquery API all I had to do was paste
in the query say what I wanted the
output dataset to be named and it would
show in my Python notebook so how long
do you think you worked on this project
overall when did you start and when it
was it kind of over yeah I would say we
began late January ok so I spent about
10 hours a week on average some weeks it
would be less always ate some weeks it
would go up to 12 to 15 hours and most
of my time we've actually spent on
preparing data sets that I could use for
my analysis right because it's really
important to have clean data that you
can analyze very easily so I just spent
a lot of time using bigquery we're just
so easy every time I ran a query just in
a few seconds I could get my results and
I could import them to go Acco lab and
do whatever I wanted with that's awesome
so thanks for talking to us and I hope
everyone out there feels like they're
just as capable and competent as our
young friend here thank you so much
[Music]
you